so what does this Arc look
like there's a picture of it right
here that's
[Music]
it this over here is the brand new Intel
Ark 580 and would you believe me if I
told you that this
$179 graphics card is batted in an RTX
3080 you wouldn't believe me would you
well you're going to have to watch the
rest of the video and then find
[Music]
looking for a cheap way to license your
windows check out hook Keys through the
links in the video description make sure
to use the C in 20 to get a 30% off
paste the license to the activation
settings and you're all done this
license is for Windows 10 but you can
upgrade it to Windows 11 for free they
also offer Microsoft Office 19 license
use the same Cod tn20 to get a 30% off
check out hooks.com in the video
description below so a little bit of a
context where does this card line up so
we've got the Intel a770 which currently
is the most powerful GPU from Intel then
we've got the a750 which are the Intel
kind of S Series you know we have i7 on
the CPUs we have seven series on the GPU
as well which are the A7 series 750 and
770 then we have this which is the
a580 which is the I5 kind of series of
gpus as you can see so this is where it
kind of slots in there and then we have
the a 380 which is the i3 you know like
the i3s we have this is not I3 but this
is the three series of Intel gpus then
the I5 and then the i7 interestingly we
haven't seen the A9 series of uh gpus
yet so I can't wait for the next
Generation because I think then we
really start to compete with the Intel's
80 series or perhaps maybe even 90
series gpus so who's the competitor of
this uh GPU so Intel is saying that this
is basically instead of the RTX 3050 or
radian a6600 something like that uh GPU
we're looking at the creat benchmarks
because what is very very interesting
about this card is that this card has
two of the Intel's best media engines
inside you know you have to get the 80
series gpus from Nvidia so that's about
,000 plus dollars to get dual encoding
or dual media engines inside the GPU for
example the 40 4070 tii actually has it
as well so it's a little bit B less than
,000 but 4080 and 4090 has dual encoders
on desktop that is on laptops actually
4070 TI doesn't have that but only 4080
and 4090 has dual media engines in there
but with this
$179 card we do have dual media engines
which are absolutely amazing for video
editors because if you didn't have Intel
quicksync with your AMD or thread Ripper
system for example then suddenly with
this $179 card you can have it and we're
going to look in a moment how these
perform in video editing benchmarks but
some of the specs then I've got RTX 350
a580 a770 and a750 here lined up there
and we can see that the process node is
actually smaller or you know newer than
the RTX 3050 GA 106 GPU which has 8 NM
Samsung process but this one has 6 nanm
tsmc interesting Intel is not using
their own chips for this but Outsourcing
it for their GPU line looking at the
Cuda CA which they're not actually
called cuda calls in Intel here and this
is completely different architecture and
different gpus you know call them
differently AMD calls something
differently Intel calls something
differently and then Nvidia calls it
differently we've got Cuda calls then
we've got render slices and XE calls and
um you know tmus and all sorts of
different things but certain kind of CES
two similar tasks so these are kind of
the similar things that we're comparing
between gpus even though technically you
can't compare these to each other
because they're a little bit different
if that makes sense in terms of the Cuda
cause whatever you know you're familiar
from Nvidia the a580 has 372 which is a
little bit more tmus we have quite a bit
more 192 and as you can see it's less
than the a750 and a770 for 10 course
tens course that's why we have stars
there we have 384 and Ticor interesting
we have exactly the same as an RTX 3050
we're using gddr6 8 GB of it and the
memory bus is
256 which is a much higher end GPU spec
than what we see on the 3050 which only
has 128 so double that and the memory
bandwidth as you can see is more than
double that as well we're using PCA 4.0
bus interface and x16 lanes for that
even though you don't actually need it
but just in case you're backwards
compatible and want to put this into BC
gen 3 or Gen 2 motherboard you're not
going to be limited by eight slots what
which RTX 3050 mights do and the card is
$179 in terms of suggested retail price
maybe it's going to vary a little bit
higher a little bit lower but it's quite
a bit cheaper than the RTX 3050 which I
can see is $200 plus doar right now and
the a750 is 230 plus and the a77 is $300
plus so it's quite a bit cheaper and has
the price going for this card but the
question is will it perform according to
its price we'll have a look if you want
to check out my test bench setup I'm
going to leave it in the description
below firstly let's have a look at
geekbench 6 and here we can see the a750
is about 9% faster in the open seal
scores and about 14 to 15% faster in the
Vulcan scores the RTX 3050 is 22 to 29%
slower in the open CL and Vulcan scores
so quite a bit better on this Intel a58
I've added another card into this
Benchmark even though this is quite a
bit more expensive the RDX 4060 TI but I
saw in some of the benchmarks this card
was so close to it so I wanted to add
that into the row of things rather than
the a770 just to see what some of the
competition and how does this perform
compared to the competition rather than
its own kind of brothers so the 46 TI is
53% faster in the open CL and about 41
40% faster in the Vulcan scores mve on
to photo editing and Photoshop the a580
is performing very very well and Intel
somehow does its magic and really gets
their gpus working really well with
Photoshop and that's the case with all
of the AR cards I've tested in Photoshop
the a750 is about 5.3% slower in the
overall scores the RTX 3050 is actually
5 to 20% slower in the overall scores as
you can see the GPU score is 20% slower
and the filter score is is 11% slower so
that is quite a big of a difference
there the RTX 4060 TI interestingly is
even slower 88.6% slower GPU score is
31% slower and the filter score is 21%
slower now bear in mind this is not just
a single test I've done this is multiple
multiple tests and calculated the
average of it and I've retested the 4060
TI and it's exactly the same all of them
have the latest drivers available at
this point in September 2023 and I'm
using the studio drivers which should
give the ultimate or the most stable
performance in Creative applications in
Lightroom classic I'm not going to test
it because really even though gpus can
accelerate certain things in there in
this Benchmark you're not going to see
the difference and I've seen the igpu
and the dedicated GPU before within a
margin of error so I'm there's no point
in actually showing these scores but now
video editing and firstly Premiere Pro
which is very very interesting so the
a750 interest inly is about 10.7% slower
in the extended overall scores and about
10% slower in the standard overall
scores and I was thinking how is this
possible I'm sure this should be slower
but that's the thing with Intel R cars
right now so the a750 I tested maybe two
weeks ago or one week ago before I got
this card and since then I'm assuming
that this 580 driver for this GPU is
even more optimized to Premiere Pro than
the previous driver I tested the a750
and this is not like a very old driver
everything's exactly the same just a
driver might be maybe one or two drivers
ago but that just shows that when you're
getting this Intel AR GPU make sure your
drivers are up to date because it does
actually matter and you can get quite a
lot more performance so I'm assuming
that the a750 will actually perform even
better now because it shouldn't be 10%
slower than the quite a bit cheaper card
in here the RTX 3050 is 19 to 21% slower
in the extended and standard overall
scores when we look at the GPU effects
in the extended or standard scores the
RTX 3050 is 35 to 36% lower that is a
huge win for the a580 and if you're
looking for a Jeep video editing card
then the a580 is the best card you can
get below $200 absolutely killer card
now the RTX 4060 TI is actually even
slower than this 580 we can see about 1%
slower in the extended overall and about
8.4% slower in the standard overall
scores which is quite a big difference
now it's not slower in every aspect of
this test as you can see the GPU effects
are a little bit better for the 4060 TI
because probably faster clock speeds and
Nvidia cards are very powerful at that
point but still working with some of the
Codex you can see intraframe for example
4060 TI
16.6% % slower in standard and extended
scores that's absolutely crazy and the
standard GPU effect scores 10.6% slower
that is a huge win for the a580 again
Arc Intel I am loving what you're doing
please keep going and give us
competition for the you know 4080 4090
you know aspect as well I want to take
things a little bit of a newer level how
does this card compare to some of the
like out of its class range I'm talking
about 3060 3080 and 4070 now looking at
the benchmarks the 3060 actually gets
absolutely wiped with the a580 it's
about 13 to 15% slower in the overall
scores it's massively slower than the
3060 and 3060 is a lot more expensive
than this guy here the 3080 look at this
over here standard and extended overall
scores4 to 5.3% slower look at the
intraframe score the intraframe extended
score is 30% slower and the same with
the standard score we can see that that
is the case with long GOP intraframe and
raw so whatever codex you're actually
using this card is much better at
encoding and decoding these and this is
because of the media engines inside
those dual media engines inside they're
absolutely killer killer options there
now you can see that the GPU effect
score is a lot faster on the RTX 380
which we can expect but if you don't use
a lot of GPU effects and just perhaps
want to render out the video or playing
back video and you not using a lot of
GPU effects this card is better than the
380 by quite a bit which is absolutely
amazing bear in mind I've tested this
with the igpu disabled on my 12900 K
which means that whatever media engine
comes with the GPU that's the only media
engine that we can use for Hardware
playback and this guy can play back some
of the hardware that Nvidia can't play
playback for example 10bit 422 h265 this
guy Hardware acceleration Nvidia and AMD
no can do and looking at the RTX 4070
which is quite a bit more expensive card
the extended overall score is about 133%
faster which is you know all right there
and the standard overall score as well
4% faster something like that so it is
faster there but look at that the
intraframe score is about 15% lower in
both of the cases and the raw standard
score is again better on the 580 which
just shows the encoding performance is a
lot better on this card now obviously
GPU effects you can see the 470
absolutely smokes it with this one but
depending which cordex you're using the
interframe especially the a580 is
absolutely killing it moving on to After
Effects and this is somewhere where I'm
getting a lot of crashes with with this
now for some reason the lower-end cards
absolutely crash my test bench with this
especially Intel card cards so none of
the Intel cards actually work in there
somewhere halfway through this they just
crash I'm still not sure why this is
happening and this is completely clean
install of the all of the drivers so
there's none of the GPU drivers in there
I've ddu all of this clean but I'm
getting a crash on After Effects now
that doesn't mean that it doesn't work
on after effects and I can assume you're
getting similar results to the Premier
Pro score if we're looking at the GPU
scores then the GPU effect scores are
probably some of them are better on the
Nvidia cards but the same time encoding
and rendering might be better on this
Arc there so that's the kind of
performance you can expect in After
Effects moving on to the vinture resolve
and here I wasn't able to complete the
test with extended score so it doesn't
test the 8K score even though it
actually matches or ticks all of the
criteria having at least 8 GB of VM to
be able to test the extended overall
score but it just wouldn't finish it
with extended overall scores and you can
see the same with a750 and an RTX 3050
actually so looking at the stand
standard overall scores we can see that
the a750 is slightly slower even though
the 4K media GPU effects and fusion
scores are better on the a750 so I'm not
sure how this gets calculated but
basically it performs very very close
within few per of the a750 that's what
we can see more interestingly the RTX
3050 is 30% faster in the standard
overall scores so Intel isn't as
optimized to the Denture resolve
software yet and we yet and have to wait
for some of the hardware updates because
you can see fusion score is 71% faster
on the 3050 and this is due to the
driver mostly as you can see the 460 TI
completes it in extended overall scores
and the standard overall scores is 42%
faster 4K media scores is 24% faster and
the fusion score is 71% faster which is
insanely higher than this a580 now
moving on to 3D performance which this
card really is you know advertised for
gamers and getting really good frame
rates but what about 3D creative
applications first of all vray it's not
supported secondly oan bch it's not
supported thirdly red shift it's not
supported either so we're going to have
to wait for you know the support for
that to come out there for Vulcan and
opencl to actually utilize this but for
blender we do have support for the a580
so let's take a look at this one the
a750 is actually 2.5 to 5% faster than
this a580 the RTX 3050 is about 16 to
20% slower than this a580 which is
actually absolutely amazing 3D
performance for this so actually in 3D
if you're using blender this is quite a
bit faster than your RTX 3050 the 4060
TI though are completely another level
as you can see
134% faster in the monster scene 88%
faster in the J shop scene and 127%
faster in the classroom scene it's a lot
better what about the power draw so
looking at this guy there the Intel
advertised TDP is actually
185 Watts which I'm never actually seen
this pull the most I can see pull is 150
wats on Fir Mark which usually
absolutely saturates the power of this
but the TDP could be the total board
power which means that it uses the other
one like vrs and other bits as well on
the GP GPU and you might be saying yeah
that's normal but actually if you look
at all the other cards and all the other
cards kind of put the the TDP onto just
the performance or Q DEA of the
calculating and all of these things
inside the GPU instead of the vram and
they go on top of that so I'm seeing 150
WS maximum pulled in there and the
temperature is about 74° which is just
all right nothing major 24.6 mbn
temperature but looking at the a750
which I have the sparkle a750 which has
a three slot C a bit bigger card that
does much better job at cooling the GPU
even though it pulls more about 180 WTS
and is 68 deges so this card pulls a
little bit more than the 3050 as you can
see and a little bit less than the 4060
TI which is interesting but cools it
down quite all right as well now I want
to mention another thing which is the
overclocking capabilities because on the
Intel Arc control you can you know move
the sliders and then extend the power
limit but when I did that you know max
out of the power you know draw limit as
well as the performance slider put it
all the max I just got a crash with this
so we're going to have to wait for the
driver's optimization and you're not
really going to get any more performance
there so I wouldn't recommend doing that
now so when we're looking at the card
design we can see two 8 Pin P power
cables or you know slots ports for your
GPU and if you know the power
limitations then usually there's about
150 watts per 8 Pin right so 150 WS here
and then you get another 75 W from the
actual PCA slot power to the GPU so in
total that will be 225 Watt and our card
pulls 150 which would be plenty extra 75
Watts what you you know wouldn't really
need but here we have two of these which
is kind of I think waste of money and
time we could have saved even more by
just adding one in there you don't
really need the secondary slot in there
because it's not going to pull that much
power this is much more power efficient
so that's that and also you can see in
terms of the cooler design they've
really tried to make this as affordable
as possible because they've just kind of
slapped on a cooler that doesn't really
fit in there because the back plate and
the PCB isn't really matching what the
cooler this is the cooler hangs over
from the top and then from the sides
there as well but this is meant to be
like the cheapest card and not
necessarily the nicest card here just
you know to give you performance four
heat pipes in there and then this back
plate is actually some kind of metal as
well and there are heat pads in there
you can see on the side there and that
will actually cool some of the vrms I'm
guessing on the back of the GPU and the
back blate does get very very warm when
actually testing this so the conclusion
of this card then I think this is
absolutely amazing card because the RTX
3050 gets pretty much wiped in every
single aspect apart from octane render
red shift and some of the other 3D
benchmarks but the point is that you're
really not going to use an RDX 3050 for
those anyway and if you're just using
blender this is a lot better than the
3050 so it's cheaper and better than the
3050 in pretty much every single aspect
apart from Dent result especially if
you're a video editor in premere Pro
this is unbelievable card and you get
unbelievable performance out of this one
like to beat the RDX 3080 quite a
marginable amount in some of the Codex
is absolutely insane really and for
photo and video editing this is the one
if you're using Adobe products Premier
Pro even after effects I'd say and
Photoshop then this card really is for
you what this card isn't for really is
3D rendering then I'd still recommend
going with Nvidia because the support is
much better even if you go with a 4060
or 4060 TI I know they're more expensive
but they will perform better in the 3D
applications apart from blender which
this is a better but other than that I
can definitely recommend the AR a 580
and knowing that there's more updates
coming to the drivers this performance
just gets better and better and better
and competition gets weaker and weaker
and weaker which is just very good news
for us because we're getting better gpus
at the low price point so if you want to
check this out I'm going to leave the
links in the description below now my
friends if you do want to build yourself
the best bank for B create PC and
perhaps want to save money and don't
build the wrong part or buy the wrong
part then I'll leave the build guides in
the description below everything is down
there whatever your budget is have a
look and enjoy those build guys
completely free you you'll find in there
as well as this card if you want to pick
it up thanks guys for watching and I'll
see you in the next one I'd love to know
what you think in the comment section
below
[Music]
bye-bye